歡迎收聽股癌，我是孟恭本集節目由 Ray Chen 正脊坐墊 EX 贊助最近市場很刺激
前面 AI 熱到不行結果臺指期夜盤殺到跌停水準
最終大跌三千多點本來只是滑一下美股
結果打開報價臺指期先瘦一大圈
心也跟著瘦投資就是這樣子，長多了不會變胖
跌下來又變瘦重點不是胖瘦
是知道哪些可以留，哪些該挪動選坐墊也是一樣
身形、臀部、坐感
偏好都不同
當然不可以使用通用尺寸坐墊 Roichen 正脊坐墊累積銷售超過 20 萬張
也是市售唯一依照不同體型需求設計的正脊坐墊
經典款提供男女不同體型兩種尺寸，現在新增正脊坐墊 EX
專門給身形高大，臀部比較有肉或是單純不喜歡坐得太緊
偏好寬鬆坐感的人
正脊坐墊 EX 完整保留支撐設計，幫助維持穩定坐姿
左右加寬 3 公分，軟墊加厚 0.7 公分，椅身增加 1.5 公分
坐起來最直接的差別就是大腿兩側包覆感降低
臀部空間更寬鬆，不會坐下去就像是喝到沒醒的紅酒
第一秒覺得人生困難
投資不能夠拗單，久坐不能夠委屈
所以如果你的身型比較高大
臀部比較有肉，或是原本就喜歡正脊坐墊的支撐
但希望坐起來更寬鬆一點
可以看一下 Roichen 正脊坐墊 EX
那我自己的心得是覺得他的支撐性是沒有改變，變大變寬更加的舒適
資訊欄這邊點下去登錄享 Gooaye 專屬無二折起
選一張真正符合自己體型的正脊坐墊
讓你憑久看盤上班的時候至少屁股跟骨盆都有基本面的支撐
這邊聽回所有學校的朋友們
那我覺得大家都應該要養成看說明書的習慣啦
那這個是來自於一個從小到大完全都不看說明書的
是後來在自己的這個股票工作裡面，因為有些規則
然後有一些這個條件，如果說你沒有搞清楚的話
會直接立刻對你的部位造成一些損害
所以後來就會對說明書稍微認真一點
可是僅限於在可能是股票相關的工作上面會去看一下說明書
那其他時候呢，其實我還蠻享受那種自己土炮硬幹亂搞亂組
不管是什麼傢俱四驅車什麼的
我覺得那是一個很快樂的過程
那當然樂高可能就比較沒有辦法，因為那個臨界真的太多
那個會勉強看一下，但是就絕大多數的時間點，一定是不看說明書
那有時候就會去嚐到一些惡果，像之前跟大家分享說
我第一次去打瘦肉症，那一開始是打 Ozempic 嘛
那就是因為我沒有看說明書
所以我就直接打到最高劑量
那還好我身體對最高劑量的反應是很低
然後現在已經進入到萌劍了
其實我現在也是在打最高劑量
我的反應也還是很低
像我剛才才剛喫完摩斯漢堡的海洋珍珠堡
加和風炸雞加和風腿塊加全糖紅茶大杯
整個把它幹掉
然後還是超餓，我不知道到底發生什麼事情
那目前已經走到了最高劑量
體重其實已經差不多到自己要的地方，所以隨時可以把它停掉
我心中想的是，我想要把內臟脂肪再稍微降一點點
那就可以去結束這個瘦瘦增脂率啦
那也因為達到了 10 毫克嘛，那所以就變成說我們在冰箱
因為那個數字是跳很快，有些我可能只打一兩劑油直接往上跳
所以我們有一堆殘劑在那邊
那之前我不知道的時候，那個殘劑油就拿來丟掉
然後後來聽院長講才知道
反正就是我們有一個醫美院長鄰居
他跟我講說，你那個收穫針它是一劑可以打四次
那四次打完之後它會有一些殘劑在裡面，那都是錢啊
你不要丟掉啊，我想說那不然送你啊
可是我不知道你那個有沒有病之類的
那個東西給我我也很害怕，你要自己把它打完啊
所以他就給我幾個針，然後就跟我講說你可以去把裡面的那個針劑抽出來
因為你有好幾管嘛，你抽出來之後你就可以把它湊成是你要的劑量
然後打到自己的身上，那我就大概就知道他有講過這件事情
然後昨天就突然間突發奇想想說，好我要來做這件事情
我就把我前面的殘劑，我當然也沒有說真的放很久
大概就一兩個月內吧
然後就把那個東西抽抽抽抽抽
然後因為我現在要打 10 毫克， 我想說 10 毫克應該就 1cc 吧
然後所以我就把它抽到 1, 然後就打
然後打的時候還遇到一些障礙， 想說奇怪， 這個針也他媽太粗了吧
它已經是抵著我的肉，那個肉都已經被戳進去了
然後還是沒有辦法進去，我想說這差小
於是我就是他媽牙一咬， 想說你有多硬啊
我就直接把它插進去打完， 打完快樂的跑到牀上躺平， 躺大概三分鐘
突然間，也不是說身體不舒服，就是一個直覺，我剛纔可能做錯事情了
就突然這樣子
我那時候一開始 OCP 打錯的時候，我一直有這個直覺
那時候我就立刻跳起來，然後去冰箱把盒子拿開來看
然後就發現盒子裡面是直接就告訴你說
反正總之你要打 10 毫克的話是 0
6CC
那我跟他打了一 CC，我到底他媽打了多少，是不是又一次我又 OD 了
所以我就很緊張，就立刻密樓下的醫美院長
就說我是不是又做錯事情了
就把流程跟他講
他就說，你打的量，其實也沒有到很多啊，就是 16.6 毫克啦，這樣算起來
那如果說你明天有不舒服的話呢
那我再去診所去拿那個止吐藥給你
或者說假設你要掉點滴的話你再來跟我講
然後我就很緊張，殺小幹，會不會出大事啊
我現在要不要去急診之類的
然後他就開始在那邊哈哈哈哈，就是我不知道
我後來覺得有些醫生反射會吧
就是他可以看到一堆血或是一些什麼抽脂出來的脂肪啊什麼的
那個你如果是一般人你應該是沒有辦法辦到
所以我覺得可能有蠻多醫師他是隱藏殺人犯之類的
就不是說他真的會殺人啦
我意思是說他們可能跟那些反正可以看到血跟肉的那些人
那某個程度上是有一些是共同的地方，他給我在那邊哈哈哈哈
我完全笑不出來，那我就說我現在該怎麼辦
他說其實也還好啦，就是可能最多就是你接下來的幾天你會反胃啊
會喫不下東西啊，或什麼的
他真的很不舒服的話，我再幫你看怎麼樣處理
結果媽的，我摩斯漢堡直接全部喫完了
所以我看起來這個瘦肉症好像真的是為我設計的藥
因為我打下去我真的是沒有什麼太多體感上的感受
那可是這邊也算是要呼籲大家啦
因為像我自己就是從小不看說明書
甚至我也覺得說不看說明書是一個很酷的事情
那經歷過這些事情之後呢
我覺得是因為剛好我的身體是對這個藥很適應
不然其實可能我第一次，一次直上最高劑量，搞不好就爆炸了
因為像有些朋友他們打那種超低劑量，什麼酒喝一口就跑去吐
聞到有油的味道就跑去吐
那你想他如果直接打到最高劑量
應該是直接往生了吧，什麼急性胰臟炎之類的
就自己身體剛好是相對幸運適應的
所以這樣子去雷他也不會有狀況
但我覺得老天給我兩次機會
一次機會就是前面我這批直上最高劑量
第二次就是自己去抽出來打的時候
然後意外的打到一個屌高的劑量
就是你市售買不到這麼高的劑量
然後外加針還沒有先換細的
用最粗的那種抽血的針直接插自己，對自己夠狠啦
那這其實不是一個太好的事情
在這邊也算是要呼籲一下大家啦
也算是對自己的提醒，就是我覺得說明書是要看的
因為最後面發現說，你看說明書你不會少一塊肉啦
只是稍微都花一點時間，你可以避免一些不必要的麻煩
不要硬推，不要硬幹，因為如果說真的有朝一日
你剛好不是打到這種對身體是友善的藥
是那一種你可能抗藥性會蠻明顯的，那就會出問題
這邊也算是給自己的一個提醒啦
也提醒大家好好的去讀說明書
大概這樣
那再來就是我們上集有聊到關於玻璃心的一些討論啦
那就有蠻多聽眾來喊
那我這邊再稍微的去做一下補充
就我覺得這個對大家應該會有一點幫助
那上集我只有提到說，你要學會去 mute 掉一些人喔
這個 mute 不只是說你可能在 Line 上面去封鎖他
封鎖的時候可能太嚴重，就是說把他那個聲音關掉，不要讓他跳通知出來
那再來呢就是有些你覺得不該見到的朋友或甚至是家人
你知道說你每次見到他，他一定不會給你正向的回饋
他一定是，就算他是愛你的， 但是呢，這個愛太沉重了，不好意思，我就不收了
就是你不要每次看到我，就是你哪裡可以做得更好或啥小的
就是這個對我們來講，有時候真的是太多了
所以你選擇去把這些人的聲音給關掉
那你把他聲音關掉之後呢
你會發現你的生活會過得更好
就是說你要讓你自己的生活之中可能圍繞一些比較正向的人
那當然這不是在講說我們要讓自己的身邊都是弄成
今天你媽長得像一條狗，然後她還說你好帥喔，今天那種頭髮超難看
這個就叫做個性
這樣可能久而久之也不好，會膨脹，會飄掉
那我們意思說就是你盡量不要去抓極端
就是你稍微的折衷一點點
你要知道說那些給你很負向的回饋的人，這是我們不需要的
那些過於奉承的人，那可能也是你不需要的
那你就挑自己可能喜歡的這些人，去稍微的聆聽他們的聲音就好
那把自己的注意力視為是一個非常重要的資產
你要知道，Meta, Google, 他們都想要去買這個東西
所以呢，這個東西是值錢的
你千萬不要把注意力放在一些不值得的人身上
這其實非常重要
那甚至是，到後來我也是非常推崇
就在說像在 YT 或在臉書上面
有時候看到一些白癡的人，我就直接封鎖掉
以前我會去跟你吵架，然後甚至我就故意去逗你
就故意去嘴你，然後我也覺得很好笑，可是後來發現說
不對，這個都是在揮霍自己的注意力，因為這些人呢
你一輩子基本上是碰不到的，那就算是碰得到的
剛好我發現你是白癡，把你過濾掉也剛好，所以呢
你只要發現這個人是個蠢蛋
你就是直接把他封鎖掉就好
因為你每天都會遇到這樣子的人
或像是在上集之後有一個聽眾視訊
他講一個很有趣，他說馬特宏峯不會管誰幫他按了一星
他就是那個馬特宏峯，喜歡他的就很喜歡，那還是會有人按他一心
那按一心的理由可能是超級白癡的，這個山太高
這個地方太冷，這個地方沒有什麼酒吧之類的
你不可能去在意每一個笨蛋的感受，所以你把他們 mute 掉
就還是回到我講的那個 mute 掉是非常重要的
那我覺得甚至會從一些比較小的事情做起啦
像我們小時候都會去接受一些禮貌教育
我覺得禮貌教育是好的，只是說你可能要讓他在某個地方要有一個終點
像小時候，我爸會跟我講說，你看到這個阿爸，你要叫阿爸
要叫叔叔，這個都沒有問題
可是有時候我們會被檢討的事
像我今天可能心情不太好，那我看到阿爸，我跟他說阿爸
可是我可能臉是比較惆悵、憂鬱或是說難過的
接著我爸就會把我抓到可能說
你該該把他捏，可能就開始臭幹你一頓之類的，或是開始威脅說
你可能後面拿一個東西就不給你喫，或是等一下就不要去拿
那個臉那麼臭，那什麼臉，那當然我覺得這個父母他們都是好的
他就希望你有用一個禮貌的態度去面對大家
這個在我們長大的時候也是有些幫助
但在我這一代呢，我覺得我就有去做一些修正
像我請我的孩子去打招呼的時候，那一開始我也沒有做好
我覺得因為我們身上就是會帶有一點爸媽帶給你的東西
那之後還是在我老婆提醒之下，我就去做一些修正
像我請我兒子去跟一些叔叔打招呼
那有時候他可能不看人家
揮個手打招呼，這個會被我糾正
我說你要眼睛要看著人家
這個是沒有問題
可是有時候我會不小心做過頭，這個叔叔很久沒看到，你去給他一個抱抱
我兒子有時候會去，有時候不去
不去的時候，我就跟他說，你不要去給人家抱抱
我老婆就跑來跟我說，為什麼他要去給人家抱抱
他又不認識他，又沒有很熟，為什麼他要給他抱抱
你想要去抱他，你自己去抱他
我覺得這個罵得真好
所以我就立刻的去懂得說，奇怪了
為什麼我的兒子要去討好一個不認識的人
幹他屁事
那個是我的朋友，那不是他的朋友
他要做到的只是要有禮貌就好
就是你要打招呼，你要正眼看人家，這是一定要做到的
那可是不會去要求說你的態度要多好或什麼的
那甚至是你今天可能心情不好，像有時候他心情不好
他去跟這個樓下的警衛看到，然後他只有揮個手
他就不看他
我還是要跟他講說，你要記得，眼鏡還是要看每一個人
為什麼你剛纔不看他，你可不可以跟我講
他就跟你講說，我可能是害羞，我可能是難過
我可能是剛才我的皮卡丘掉到地上
我心情不好什麼的
那我覺得這個是蠻重要的，就是讓他知道說他沒有必要去討好每一個人
因為如果說你真的要讓身邊的每一個人都非常的好受的話
你一定就是最難受的那個人
因為總是有些東西需要被釋放出來的，能量是守恆的
那所以在後來對孩子的教育上面
我覺得我自己也悟到了一件事情
就是當我今天覺得我不想跟人家講話的時候
其實我就是可以不用跟人家講話的
我不用說什麼每個人密我的人我一定要回你
因為我現在就是不想跟你講話
或甚至我好不容易決定要跟你講話
結果你又在講一些很白癡的東西
那我就只好再繼續不跟你講話
那維持這樣子的一個做法呢
一開始你會覺得我這樣會不會變成是一個拍到頂的人或什麼
可是最終你就會發現這樣子你就對自己有一個完整的交代
而且你會過得非常的快樂
那這可能也可以再稍微補充給那位聽眾或是其他有遇到類似問題的人
就是盡可能最大程度的去降低一些負面的東西對你的影響
不要覺得是不好意思或者說可能會冒犯到別人
因為別人在冒犯你的時候，他也是完全不擔心啊
那你為什麼要擔心說你可能有人冒犯到他之類的
而且我們其實已經是拿很多誠意來面對大家了
那有時候呢，自己心裡面的東西還沒有處理好之前
我沒有辦法顧弄、微笑、自作堅強地去跟你好像說我什麼事情都沒有
這個是沒有辦法做到的事
所以這個蠻重要的啦
希望大家都可以在這之中獲得一些想法，大概這樣
那接下來我們來進入節目的話題啦
那昨天應該大家都跟我一樣蠻忙的，就是要去買 SpaceX 的股票
那我自己是有去做申購，那除了申購之外呢
後來等它跑到刺激市場的時候也是有去做交易
本來想說 10 點，那後來是有 delay，那我去買的時候是 160 幾啊
我申購的時候當然就是那個申購價，那後面是有再買到 160 幾
那我覺得接下來幾天應該都會再持續的去點一點
有點像是說去支持一個這種太空的夢想吧
那我們如果今天是把 SpaceX 公司拆開來看的話
它就是一個衛星公司跟火箭公司
然後還有 AI 公司
那其中呢，衛星是目前它賺錢的引擎啦
那火箭的話，我相信有朝一日也有機會可能帶來蠻不錯的一個收益
只是那個夢想可能是放在相對遠的一個地方
那 AI 的話呢，可能就是要回歸到像我們前面跟大家聊到的這個
它如果有辦法在低谷衛星上面去放一些 data center 啊
然後或者是假設說他目前是把 AI 算力出租出去嘛
因為他們算是打掉重練，那如果這個東西可以成功的再重新的把它拋起來的話
那說不定這邊也可以帶來一些收益
所以簡單來講就是說除了衛星以外的東西呢都算是一種本夢比的狀態
那我覺得像這樣的公司你不用太認真的去算它的估值啊
剛好我在我的臉書上有寫這樣子一個東西
那這個估值的討論在市場上算是一個大哉問
什麼叫做便宜的東西，什麼叫做合理價，什麼又叫做太貴
我覺得是便宜的東西，你可能不覺得是便宜
我覺得是一個很划算的 Bargain
那你可能覺得說，媽，你是一個臭盤子
舉例來說，我會去買一些公仔放在家裡
那我會去買一些遊戲王卡
像現在我會去買一些紅酒
那我買的紅酒可能有些是幾千塊
有些上萬，有些上幾十萬的，甚至搞不好到百萬去了
那在一些人的眼中他覺得說，你是一個白癡，因為喝酒是傷身的東西
為什麼你要去喝酒
可是在我的角度去看你在做的事情，我可能也覺得你是白癡
所以其實一樣的道理，後來你會發現，拉到投資市場也是這樣子的
就是我們當然可以用一個相對 universal 的語言去看
就像是說一家公司的 EPS 跟營收成長率
然後去給你一個 Price-to-Sales 或是 Price-to-Earning 的 Ratio 這個東西算是比較 Universal
就大家可以去接受說，那可能大概到某個地方它是一個相對便宜的
可是你要注意到說，就是有兩家公司
它可能就算有一樣的財務數字跟一樣的成長性
基本上就是 Identical，在財務上面是一樣的公司
可是因為一個是在做隨便舉例紡織
然後一個是在做衛星相關的，那你就注意到說
他們的 P 乘數可能就有一個非常大的差距
為什麼
因為大家覺得衛星是一個比較有夢想的東西
那這時候你當然可以選擇去買你的紡織公司嘛
便宜價值股，那當然有些人就會選擇要去買那個成長股
相對貴，那可能是 trade 在一個超級高的地方
那這時候呢，你不要以為說那個便宜的會贏喔
在過去一段時間
其實我們注意到說價值股蠻多時候
他是沒有辦法去跑贏市場中的那一些成長股
那甚至後來成長股跟價值股的界線我覺得有越來越模糊
因為以前會有一個印象是說成長股本身就是沒有價值的
但後來給人家發現是說成長股他們很多時候只是價值放在後面
等到你發現它是一個價值股的時候
它可能已經是過完最飆的一個階段
其實拿最近的案例來講就好，就像是記憶體股
記憶體股現在大家看都是非常的便宜
可是它在起漲點的時候你覺得它非常貴
那一樣的道理就是你現在可能去算一些被動元件
像我自己去看春田，我也覺得春田很貴啊
可是如果說春田後來的 EPS 狂拉
它真的漲價成功，那種一系列的什麼 AI 的需求把它推上去的話
到時候你看它搞不好又變成一個 PE 搞不好在 20 倍以下的東西
那到時候你就覺得它便宜，可是呢
你覺得它便宜的時候它其實已經碰到上面去了
所以估值是一個蠻藝術的東西啊
甚至我覺得估值的重點並不是在估的當下去證一個對錯
而是你估在別人的前面，這纔是估值的重點
不管你是玩成長股還是價值股
你要做的是，你買的地方你知道你買進之後
後面還會有源源不絕的人進來買
然後你可以出貨給他們，你可以賣在一個更高的地方
那這樣就是一個好的估值
而不是去比說什麼絕對數字或怎麼樣
因為你大可以在市場上找到一堆所謂的真的超便宜
殖利率又高的東西，然後你買了放，喔好安心，結果它連漲都不會漲
這個其實是有很多的案例
所以像我不會去認為說 SpaceX 這樣的公司是一個賣夢
或是像現在網路文章有很多在那邊寫說什麼，啊這就是一個炒作
這是一個本夢筆，這就是去賭它夢想實現或什麼的
我絕對不用去扯那麼遠啦
簡單來講就是說，會信的就是會信，不會信的就是不會信
有時候去買紡織股的跟買這些太空股，那完全是兩個不一樣的人
然後就回到我們之前講的
你根本沒有必要去說服對方
你也沒有辦法說服對方，大概這樣子
那後來在盤中也出現一個有趣的現象
就是一些在過去跟衛星火箭相關的股票
不管是什麼 RKLV,ASTS,FLY，就是這些跟衛星或是通訊有關係的股票
其實他們都出現了一個大逃殺的狀況
那其實像這樣子的劇本在過去也是看過幾次
本來是 rumor 的東西，然後開始實現之後呢
過去跟著題材一起上來的東西
蠻多就會趁機的提款
這個就要呼應到我們一月的節目，那時候有跟大家聊到
因為那時候我是買了蠻多 Starlink 相關的股票
因為我們在供應鏈已經有看到一些變化
那後來我自己是差不多在二三月左右就刪了啦
那理論上其實我是要做到像最近這個時候，然後再出
那只是因為臺股今年真的是太熱鬧，太多選項了
所以我就已經提早就有去動了
然後像日股的 Macro 的話，那也因為說後來去切被動元件
所以就有去做一些調整，那也注意到 MACO 其實也是回檔一陣子了
所以看這個就是在 SpaceX 剛上市之後的一些衛星或是通訊股的表現
那一天是不準啊，如果說你再持續的去注意幾天
如果它是持續的軟掉的話
那應該就是有蠻多資金會趁這個機會就要出貨
因為你知道人家已經從前面可能已經蹲點蠻久了
所以就趁這個機會當成是一個出貨的時間點，大概這樣
那之後如果說 SpaceX 的記報或怎麼樣有什麼有趣的變化
一樣我們就會在節目上面跟大家分享
我覺得這個會有一點類似說像我自己去持有特斯拉一樣
它會有一點那種就是我是去相挺它
那我覺得這個題材很酷的一個背景去做持有
當然我的目標還是要賺錢啦
那只是呢就是不會去針對它的估值去做太多的討論
就還是回到我剛剛前面講的
你大可以在市場裡面去買估值便宜的東西，你去買看看嘛
你就看會不會漲
很多時候估值便宜的東西不一定會漲，所以在我們的 portfolio 裡面
有些東西可能是屬於便宜的
那些東西是屬於那種賣夢的
就題材對的，那反正總之呢
就是看到時市場的表現是怎麼樣
我們再去做調整
如果有朝一日大家都開始回頭去拉一些價值股的話
你會注意到滿手就會變成價值股，就你會往那個方向去靠
會持續的用加減碼去做一些調整，大概這樣子
接下來我們來看一下臺股盤面
那我先大概講一下自己的想法
就是我覺得行情走到這個地方
應該某個程度上是跌完了啦
就我會認為是比較偏向是跌完了
除非後面有一些新的事件的產生
那首先呢，要先知道說像臺股大跌已經跑去摸跌停的那一天
那個算是在市場上面其實並沒有什麼太多的消息出來
然後後來就是 CPI 的公佈嘛
那其實對市場的影響也是
你就注意到說是慢慢的限縮掉了
那再來呢就是川普有威脅說要去奪島作戰嘛
然後後來又說我不打了什麼的
那你就注意到對於市場的影響
其實真的都是慢慢的在淡化之中啊
所以我覺得這一波有點像是說在掉下來的時候
他把所有的壞消息都一次丟出來了
那所以如果炸一炸，然後之後沒有再繼續破底的話
我個人就覺得說可能修正就到這個地方
所以像我自己就是持續的把籌碼推進去，我就是有再繼續的去做買進
那當然我知道在市場裡面現在一定會有些人會看說什麼
他會回到季線或什麼的
那如果真的回去季線的話
就變成說我這部分就會被套到了
但其實整體來看真的是沒差，因為這波真的拉太遠了
以我這個角度，我不會想要去等到季線
我現在就已經開始持續的去做一些買進
因為我覺得市場裡面其實還是有蠻多的故事跟題材可以持續的去看
那當然 SpaceX 有沒有辦法再帶動新一波的衛星啊
火箭相關的類股，這個是有待商榷，我們要稍微看一下
以美股的第一天的表現來看，應該是趁機拿來出貨了
那我們就來觀察一下下禮拜的臺股會怎麼樣跑
或許呢，有機會衛星也會變成是一個就再拿出來的族羣
但也有可能就到這邊去做結束
因為畢竟其實像我們跟大家分享
它從一月多就已經開始一路在做反應了
那些其實都是漲很多的東西
所以可能就是說趁大家開始看到報紙，要去找衛星股的時候呢
預判你的預判，然後去給人家出貨出到爆炸，這要再觀察一下
那再來呢，被動元件在這個禮拜也有新的一些消息傳出來
針對一些大型的 ODM 跟 EMS，我們是有注意到說有漲價成功的情形
其實也注意到現在開始有蠻多的券商報告去寫嘛
不管像是什麼花旗啊或是這個 JP 啊或是我記得好像 GS 也有寫
那聽說在下個禮拜還下禮拜某個這個 A 家的也要進去寫
就是喜歡去用那個數字當成是關鍵字的
類似說聯發科就是要目標價 2454
臺積電就是 2330，那當然國巨有目標價 2327
我們看後面會不會有這樣的情形發生
開始有越來越多人把目標價持續的去做上修
其實以我們現在所看到的漲價狀況來講，我覺得有點超出我自己的預期
像我本來是有去算了一個劇本
如果說從現在開始它就是去複製 2018 的行情
那 2018 的行情是怎麼樣
就是說可能營收是翻了兩倍，可能毛利率也是上去了一倍
那這樣子的話， EPS 大概可以跑到這樣的一個數字
那有去跟身邊的一些朋友討論
那只是呢，在最近的漲價裡面
特別是我們看到已經有那種確定漲成功的一些料號
那看起來的一個情形是，如果按照這樣的速度的話
我們本來是規劃說大概可能要漲六到七次才會到我們的 terminal 的一個位置
那照加這個速度的話，其實只要兩次的漲價就會直接達到 terminal 的數字
所以就是有機會還有上手的空間，簡單來講就是這樣子
那當然我們到這個節骨眼已經不會再去針對股價去做太多的評論
那天地良心啦，我們也不會在這個股價已經漲很多才開始講
我們很早就跟大家講，那只是那時候也是怎麼講
熬了一陣子，你也不知道這個東西到底什麼時候會噴
那只是現在就噴出去，那已經噴出去我們就不去針對股價去做太多的評論
但整體來說呢，我們去 follow 基本面的角度
持續跟大家分享就是我們現在有注意到它漲價是有成功的
而且漲的料號不只是大家最缺的 AI 核心的料號
甚至是一些周圍影響的或是中小尺寸的小東西
也開始有一些漲價的出現
這個其實有點像是說不只是韓系、日系
連臺系現在有些也開始扮演漲價領頭羊的角色
大家去針對一些料號去做漲價
然後它也成功漲價成功的話
其他人就會跟著去漲價，所以這一波被動零件其實按照目前的角度看起來
特別是我們有注意到在業內的一些比較大型的廠商
目前還沒有太多大擴產的計畫出來，所以有機會它會走一個
我們去類比記憶體，但我們不知道去形容說像記憶體這麼大一波
我們只好去形容說它會走的相對長，跟過往的一個循環
呃，的那個週期比起來會相對長一點
因為大家可能是比較不會這麼的短視近離
像過去的一個大潮是，呃，他甚至是很快就讓大家去辦公室裡面去做競標
你要買多少料，你就進來用喊的啦，那你喊比較高
你就可以把它買走，那這樣子有點那種殺雞取卵的行為呢
後來就是會導致說可能在一些客戶的影響之下
你的價格東西就掉很低，那在這一波呢
我們就注意到說大家都是相對節制的
在擴產或者說在漲價方面其實都是比較小心的
你看到一些那種比較暴利的漲價
我們看到那種中位數到幾十趴以上
那個應該是也是建立過談判之後
然後確定說就是有這樣子的一個需求才會導致的現象
那我們目前也注意到在日系這邊呢，也是跟韓系一樣
就是跟緊的開始有去做一些配貨的操作
那雖然我們自己有一些產業圈的朋友有跟我講說
因為我想說我聽說某日系已經開始在做配貨
他說可能在一兩個月前就已經有這樣做
那我說我們投資圈的可能那個鴿子飛比較慢
就是我們現在才聽說到有配貨的情形
當這個配貨的情形開始出來之後呢
當然就是會更加的去檢驗說到底這個需求是真是假
因為前面可能是大家 FOMO 在那邊亂叫貨嘛
那或者說可能是在反映成本的一個漲價
那可是當開始要去做配貨
開始要去釐清說到底每個客戶要多少
因為像是說那時候 NVIDIA，那它也會去透過它的 ODM OEM 去釐清說到底終端客戶是誰嘛
第一個就是因為這個東西不可以出給中國
然後第二個是我要知道說裡面有沒有 overbooking 的一個現象產生
當全面配貨的一個機制把它 run 下去之後
我覺得很快就會實際的去反映說目前的供需的狀態到底是怎麼樣
以現在來看，我們不評論股價，我們用產業的角度
我覺得價格可能都還在一個上漲的過程之中而已
所以後續再來做一些觀察
再來就是 Amfib 這邊推出了 Fable
我在過去一陣子有稍微去做使用一下，我覺得還是一如往常
Farbit 的模型都是非常好用的喔
但是有趣的是呢，Fable 目前是在海外是已經受到了美國出口的一個管制
那大家如果想要去打開你的模型
一開始我自己在 Perplexity 上面還是可以間接的去用到
剛剛在錄節目前我去測試就發現說也被鎖起來了
就是呢，他認為說這個東西有可能會幫助到一些什麼境外勢力啊
或是可能就是像這個 Dario Amodi 自己講的，很危險，對啊
就我前面說的嘛，你一直講自己東西很危險很恐怖
你就是會去喫監管鐵拳，爽，就雙死了
但說不定這個就是他要的喔，就是呢
我自己也會喫到一點監管
可是你們就被監管給封死了，爽
就我還是不太知道為什麼他會這樣說
那我這方面是蠻認同，Panther 跟 Alex Karp 講的就是 OpenAI 的 Sam Altman 跟 Anthropic 的 Dario Amodi
他們不知道自己有多討人厭
他們真的是非常討人厭的那種個性
當然現在已經注意到他們兩個的修辭都有去做一點調整
就是不像過去是一昧的訴諸恐懼
但他訴諸恐懼的一個後果現在就看到了
就是可能會開始面臨一些監管
現在他是不給海外的人用
說不定後來還會再有更多的監管鐵拳打下來，那嚴重一點的話呢
這搞不好會影響到他整體的市場的觸及度
那搞不好也有可能在某次的修正就會被拿來當一個故事
所以就會不太明白為什麼前面一直要去訴諸恐懼
反正我不知道，我看這兩個人的臉我覺得這兩個人都怪怪的
但是呢，不能否認的是他們的產品真的都是非常的好用
只是說在自己的那種感性上
就像那時候我跟大家分享說
我覺得 All in Parts 裡面那個 Polly Haberty，以前我也是蠻喜歡她的
後來就覺得這個人怪怪的
其實有很多那種 Investment Hero 或者是很有聲量的人
你後來去觀察他們都會注意到他們有一點奇怪喔
那蠻多時候我覺得我們自己的直覺是蠻準的
當我覺得你怪怪的時候，你可能真的還怪怪的
那後面可能就會開始出現一些
就是我們認為說你這樣做會帶來的一些代價啦
那總之呢，我目前去用的那個 Fable 的模型
雖然沒有很長的一個使用時長
但是算是非常的全面，而且它的速度是相對快的
當然它的 Token 也是燒得很快
所以就會回到最經典的那個討論
也就是未來可能是在一些前端的實驗室或是科技巨頭
他們去做一些比較前沿項目的時候會去用這些最高價的模型
那後面會有一個市場會由一些相對低價相對便宜的模型去做滿足
甚至是由低端模型直接去做滿足
那到時候 edge computing 就會變成是一個很大的話題
那我覺得那一天的到來其實已經不遠了，也就是在過去的兩三年
我們認為 edge computing 是一個時間未到的東西
可是當今天你把前沿模型拉到非常強大
然後在套之前有個聽眾講了
大概開放模型是在這些閉鎖模型後面的半年
所以如果說閉鎖模型在這些開放模型已經是摸到一個新的結界之後
在後面也拉到了一個相對強的水準的話
那透過低端的算力就可以完成
絕大多數
大家可能在一兩年前 AI 可以辦到的事情
就我們現在講一兩年前，可能你已經覺得說一兩年前 AI 就不錯了
那如果是在一兩年前，去講一兩年前，就是說三四年前的話
那時候的 AI 是威爾史密斯一開始喫那個義大利麵
就是會甚至有點那種恐怖股效應，很猥褻，很噁心這樣
那只是後來它的發展是越來越好
所以如果可以這樣去推的話
我們不要抓半年，我們就抓一年
就是你等到可能以現在你往回看一年
其實去年的模型就不錯嘛，那如果今天是 2028，你往回看一年
2027 的模型其實對我們絕大多數人來講一定就是非常夠用
然後這些東西可以直接完全的 run 在第一端，那到時候
地端的裝置就是有機會去迎來一波爆發啦
那以及呢就是如果說這些最前端的模型
後面開始會去喫到一些監管鐵拳的話
有可能市場的偏好就會從去追求這些大模型
然後跟大 Cluster 的運算開始跑去 Edge 那邊
所以有可能 Amodi 這樣的一系列的說法會導致這樣一個新的趨勢的產生
當然現在要去扣這個可能是太早
但是已經開始有聞到這樣子的一個味道
就當某些東西開始會出現一些利空去打擊它的時候
那有可能大家就會把方向轉去另外一個可能成長性沒有這麼好
但是也不錯那同時呢，可能是籌碼乾淨
又相對在低季期的地方這就是有機會在後面會被大家注意到的東西好
大概這樣，那這集節目先聊到這邊
我們接下來去 Q&A 的部分第一位
糖醋魚骨，孟恭五癌孟恭還記得第一次搭商務艙的感覺嗎
想像一下未來諾亞的同學跟他炫耀
自己搭過經濟艙諾亞回來跟你抱怨說為什麼別人都有搭過經濟艙
就我沒有第一次搭商務艙的感覺就是蠻新鮮的啦
然後你就會想要去把每個飲料都點一次這樣
然後現在去搭商貨艙的感覺就是上去就直接睡覺
甚至有些餐我就不喫了，反正我就是上去睡覺，我只想要趕快到目的地
那也不會在意說什麼啊
他旁邊的那個小包裡面有什麼東西有乳液
有拖鞋就完全不屌
我只想要睡覺
目前是變成這樣子
一個情形就是不會覺得這是一個什麼特別的東西那孩子的話有沒有搭過競技場還是有搭過啊
就一些短程的話還是會搭競技場啊
就是不會覺得說什麼每個都一定要買商務廠這樣那當然如果有商務廠的話
就會去選商務廠那只是如果是一些比較短程的
甚至會覺得說
大家可以這樣做一排是蠻有趣的
所以是蠻有彈性的
就我很常跟大家講的
就如果說你真的是一個在資產上面是有餘裕的人
其實你比較常見的樣態應該是
至少以我觀察身邊的朋友
就是你是很自在的，你可以喫路邊攤，你也可以喫貴的
你可以做船貨廠，甚至你可以包機，已經有蠻多人這樣子做
你也可以去做經濟廠，就只是看當下的感受是怎麼樣
那些會一昧去追求說，沒有什麼我不做，沒有什麼我不喫
沒有什麼我不喝，那個應該都是才剛起來的那種爆發戶就會有這樣子的一個現象
就自卑啦，自卑就會變這樣子
下面一位， 奇怪名字都有人用，愛阿公，猛公希望哪天可以遇到你，愛心，愛你
下面一位，奈米小谷迷，股癌節目優質一聲推，孟公大大好
聽到你說以後有可能會突然停播
就好像突然少了一個好朋友的感覺
雖然我們完全不認識，謝謝你每週兩次分享產業最新動態
祝孟公一家平安，順利安歌，諾亞平安，長大愛你，我愛你
其實我並不是要去塑造一個好像要跟大家分開的一個氛圍或什麼
我只是像以往我也都一直都講
我一直跟大家講說我不知道為什麼會有人要跟我拍照
我也不知道這個節目可以到什麼時候
其實我從以前到現在，十年如一日，沒有到十年，四五年
五六年，我覺得態度都是一樣的
對我自己來講，我維持這樣一個心態的好處是我不太怕失去
我跟自己身邊有一位朋友比較極端，他就是隨時都做好失去一切的準備
我不是做好失去一切的準備，我是做好隨時可以抽身不被影響的準備
那我覺得這個對我來講是在心理上比較健康的
不管是可能節目有朝一日突然間就停掉
或是我的一些小投資如果有朝一日我不做的話
我也知道說我可以找誰去做接手幫我看著
或是說節目有一天突然間覺得說負擔太大想要休息一下之類的
那我可能隨時可以離開，或是說我之後想回來的時候搞不好還會有些人要期待我回來之類的
就是我會去做好這樣子的各種心理準備
就是我不會覺得說什麼這個是我的節目
所以我一定要死抱著它，我要去維持它
我一定要讓它很好什麼的
我對所有東西的態度都是我覺得它會來，它也可能會走
那所以就是用這種比較中性
比較像是過客的態度去看它
那剛好在生日那一天，我這樣一個感想發揮出來而已
大概是這樣
那不是說什麼立刻要跟大家說再見，但是一定會有說再見的一天
下面一位
PVENRT 母體侷限，AI 要怎麼取代人類
它知識最大的限制就是人為它的那些東西
目前來說是這樣子沒錯啦
但是呢，AI 如果等到它有夠多的知識跟智慧可以自己去做訓練甚至提升的話
它就有可能不再需要外面的資訊
它也可以去玩出自己的一套東西
那當然我們講自己的一套東西
我自己會認為比較偏向是工程或者是 Coding 這類的東西
如果你說是一些人文的東西
那應該還是要有很多的 input 進去
要跟著時代去做變化
所以它不是一言以蔽之可以用很簡單的方法去把它分類的東西
下面一位不是美國店長的 Captain
好久沒有留言抽獎的氣氛仔
去年沒有被唸到再來一次
從麥克風裝盤時期就一直聽到現在的氣氛仔，感謝每週持續的分享
最近都是聽到跟觀音ㄉㄨㄞ求祝福，先不管觀音ㄉㄨㄞ，括號諾亞音
單純祝孟公大生日快樂，全家健康平安悠
611 邁入不惑的我也生日快樂悠
我很想求抽獎抽到我哈哈 0 分下面一位
好久沒有聽到秋狗幹你娘
忘了姓名的請跟我來，非常感謝這位不是美國店長的 Captain 的祝福
那也希望你生日快樂，下面一位，Sam，但不是 Altman，我考上了
超爽的，孟恭大午安，曾在 EP631 留言，祈願考上研究所
感謝孟恭跟觀音朵來的保佑
很開心能夠回來留言考上交大資工了
交大志工是那個交大巴塞烤香腸那個嗎
放進烤箱裡滋滋滋，香味撲鼻又超好喫，是那個嗎
那也以還願捐出生活費並開始喫素
希望未來研究求職都順利
今年和女友去紐西蘭玩半個月，開露營車小環島
沿途的風景真的很美，相信諾瓦安哥會喜歡 Queenstown 的 Sky Lodge 的
以及紐西蘭的羊肉超好喫，推薦給孟恭
祝孟恭大全家健康平安，事事順心
各位好，愛寶們，繼續在股市探大錢
愛您，我妹愛您
希望這個 Sam 但不是 Altman 在交大職工可以過得快樂、平安、順利畢業
It's KMAR，第一次留言應該要講點快樂的事情吧，MK 您好
第三次留言希望被唸到，感謝一路以來分享生活大小事跟產業觀察
收穫真的很多，我也藉由您的一些分享思路去反思各種決策
真的是始料未及會發生的體驗
那最後希望可以向背後的觀音ㄉㄨㄞ許願我家二寶快來臨
我願意加碼半個月的薪水捐給家扶基金會，謝謝
OK, 那我們希望你的惡寶可以盡快的來臨，他健康平安
下面一位，黑人給我閉嘴，他講的不是我講的，歐巴馬
黑人給我閉嘴， 歐巴馬
老公之前在金華城都放搖滾， 那有 follow 到 Foo Fighters 的新歌嗎
超久沒有聽這團，去打電波跟醫師聊到你也喜歡搖滾
才知道有新專輯，甚至有新的詢願
聽一聽熱音社的回憶都毀了
最後祝我遠方不曾磨滅的兄弟孟恭
實在是生日快樂，平安健康
To keep alive a moment at a time,but still inside a whisper to a riot.好，他這個是那個...And I walk again
I believe that I'm waiting long enough...那一首歌
Foo Fighters 的歌真的是非常的熱血啦
就是在那一種...唉...不知道，就是你們今天突然間要決定去開啟一個新的計畫
還是要做什麼事情的時候
把 Foo Fighters 的歌拿出來炸一下
會突然覺得說，嗯，我們什麼事情都一定會完成
什麼事情都一定可以達成那種感覺
那時候有沒有去放 Foo Fighters 的歌
有，因為其實已經喜歡他們蠻長一段時間了
Foo Fighters 的主唱就是以前的 Rana 的鼓手，這應該蠻多人都知道
所以就是一脈單傳，我也會持續這樣子聽過去
簡單來講就是說，大家去搞的一些 side project 或是一些新的東西，我們都會去跟
Foo Fighters 算是我蠻喜歡的團，大概是這樣
用專角氣看起來兩光兩光，聚焦的星星光芒成為光芒耀眼的道路
不知道為啥有種價值觀崩壞的氛圍
以前聽到人家做生意有賺錢是一件高興的事情
現在但凡投資報酬率不高的生意都會說不如放股票
萬物非漲，連價值觀也非漲，萬物非漲
那有時候在想夭壽那些房子店面到底誰花得起
沒有想不到只有花不起，知道比較會把快樂給賠掉
但不想跟別人比還是會有人找你比較
【莫名被找架打，好奇在這個世道下何謂人情跟道德
】我覺得現在還是一個賺錢的時間點，應該搞不好持續到 2027
2028 都還是有機會，所以先持續的尻錢
等到市場開始進入空頭的時候，我們就來竹林七賢
大家就來輕談，來聊一下什麼叫做人情跟道德
先努力的賺錢就好
那你講的這個事情其實是發生在很多地方，在創投界也有啦
就像聽說在這個業界最常被問的問題就是
為什麼我要投你我不要去買臺積電
其實這種在我的角度就覺得就叫幹話啦
那你就去投臺積電啊，你做啥小創投
你就去投臺積電啊，沒有人阻擋你啊，你去投臺積電啊
你自己要來做創投的，媽的怪我囉
我也不會去問我們校南投資的團隊為什麼不要投臺積電
不是啊，我來這邊就是來幹大的，我就是來賭大的
我要就是要賭一個我們做出什麼世界級的遊戲啊
我要就是 go big，不然我就回家嘛
不然我就去買臺積電嘛，我幹嘛還要來這邊賭
所以我敢來我就是敢賭啊
所以我覺得你在外面聽到這種去做比較的
就是說我為什麼不要去買股票
你去啊，但是你不要拿這個去貶低人家
我覺得這是很很下乾的，就你也沒有賺多少啊，老實講是這樣啊
就說我們這種在股票賺的不錯的，我們不會這樣子講話
就是像我們剛剛前面講的就是，呃
沒有多少錢的最喜歡去講說什麼東西我不打
什麼東西我不喫，好像自己很屌
然後什麼你這個東西我不要投
他一定是沒有多少錢在講這種話
因為真的有錢的人會想要去做一些分散啊
我不敢說每一個啦，但是蠻多都這樣子，就是我有錢的
我去做一點創投，他其實甚至是做一個理念的
或是他想要去讀一個報紙
他覺得在自己市場，他可以穩定搞好錢
可是他想要在這個一級市場去撈到一個大的就好玩啦
所以你不會用這樣子的話去羞辱或是說去故意把人家壓低啊
那我知道其實也有蠻多 founder 都有提到這樣子的東西
因為我有時候海巡會看到就會提到說可能
今天去募資的時候，對方去講這種話
那對方就不是真心要來投你的
他只是想殺價，或是說他搞不好是真心的
但他就是希望價格可以再壓到更低一點
所以這就是他的一個話術
我覺得沒有必要這樣去講話去羞辱別人
人生不是隻有股票，就是說你股票是因為現在很好
大家都這樣看，就類似說之前可能房地產很好的時候
大家也覺得說就是無腦買房就好
反正只要每次哪個都很好的時候
就會有很多這樣子的人出現
但是我們不要變成這樣子討人厭的人
然後再來講說，會有人來找你比較，這就是我剛剛前面講的
你要去 mute 掉這些人，就是你盡量不要讓這些人影響到你
因為現在確實有很多是那種笑貧不笑娼的這種價值
觀在市面上去做流竄
好像說就是要有錢，有錢就是要讓大家知道自己有錢或什麼
我有時候在想說，因為臺灣的治安是比較好一點
就是說如果你知道你這樣子，你去歐洲這樣子 PO
我會怕，因為我們自己每年會在歐洲一段時間嘛
老實講，你真的不會想要去做太 flashy 的事情
因為那真的是會幫自己惹麻煩
可能臺灣是一個相對安全的地方
所以就很多人就公為就紅蝦
那甚至裡面有很多是假的
就他搞不好根本就沒有這個錢
他是混在裡面，然後講自己怎麼樣
所以就不要去受到這些人的影響
我覺得還是專注自己本身的價值，然後跟自己過去的比較
這個是比較重要的
我是來自海外且今年剛聽的小矮粉，孟恭起家怎麼帥成這樣
補一個六月生日快樂，一聽就愛不釋手
想問孟恭剛入股市的小菜雞要怎麼樣收集到市場的資訊呢
也沒有太多券商的報告，尤其是目前同時也在創業
現金流不穩定，只用部分的資金操作
但希望時間允許研究並操作
那能夠多一點主動配置的話要怎麼樣進行比較好
雖然最近的盤動盪，但還是希望可以從這一部分多一點參與市場
那除了被動投資，搭配多一些主動選股的操作慢慢累積
感謝孟恭這麼優質的好節目，那真的佩服孟恭
也祝你跟你的家人們都平安健康
非常感謝這位海外的小矮粉，蠻怪的
反正總之呢，如果你想要獲得更多的報告的話
我覺得比較簡單的方式就是你多開一點戶
你就可以獲得蠻多這種券商銷售的一個報告
那更進階一點的話呢，就是等到你的交易量夠大的話
你就去開一個法人部的戶頭
那像這樣子法人部的戶頭，他們有辦法再幫你搞到更多的資源
一般就會有一些可能 LINE 羣啊
或甚至你可以直接跟你的營運人對話
他就會幫你找
一些海內外的報告或是一些 call memo 都會把你丟來
這個就等於說可以再更上一層樓
那再來可能就是要有一些同好啦
因為每個人的注意力是有限的嘛
我今天 call 公司，call ABC，你 call DEF，那我們就來做交換
那這樣子大家都可以獲得很多的情報
所以它是慢慢的，它沒有那種一步登天的方法
那蠻多人都想要問一步登天的方法
但真的沒有，那都是靠累積
那老實講你說累積到很多
你的績效就會比之前更好嘛，我得說有累積真的有差
可是到後面那個邊際效益會遞減
甚至你會有一點受害於資訊太多
太多雜訊，或是說就算你的資訊是對的
可是你的資訊的頻率太高
導致像我之前就跟一個大哥討論過
因為那時候我要跟他對一些投片數字
他直接跟我講說
他都沒有在看投片數字
我想說你媽的
你這麼大的一個分析師
你這麼有名
大家都在看你的報告
你沒有在看投片報告你是唬我的吧
他說他真的都不知道那些數字
他說那個叫 Noise
那這句話影響我非常大
因為老實講在 2023
2024 如果你可以掌握到一些前段、後段
封裝段的各種數字
你就可以賺錢
那直到現在
你已經很少聽到人家去追什麼投片數字嘛
或者是說可能今天 Oracle 或者是 Meta
他媽的垃圾，Rex，你應該很久沒有看到這個數字
因為這一招已經是沒有用了
就在後面在市場上是越來越鈍化的
那像那個大哥他的說法就是說他不去看這種
因為你一下上修，你後面又下修，你下修之後，後面又再上修
那意義在哪
我只要抓到大方向，我只要知道說哪些廠商可以喫到這些大單
我這樣下就可以，所以他的做法你甚至搞不好看新聞就好了
你還不用看一堆什麼研究報告，懂嗎
所以有資訊很好，但是資訊並不是一個絕對必要，沒有就會死掉的東西
甚至我覺得很多時候是在考驗你的眼光啦，大概是這樣
那下面一位，臺股雲霄飛車，網美鐵拳教育超好看
五星好評最愛，網飛最近的韓劇新片鐵拳教育超好看
有打打殺殺的片段，探討各種學校的不良案例
內容也有提到不少小孩的部分
應該對您會有所幫助，哪一代有機會也在 YouTube 念留言嗎
那首先非常感謝你的推薦，然後再來講 YouTube 念留言啊
之後有機會可能可以試看看
我覺得目前就是 Apple 跟 Spotify 算蠻不錯啦
因為已經算是可以 cover 到絕大多數的聽眾
或許以後可以再加一個 YouTube
可是因為 YouTube 有時候會有白癡啊
就 YouTube 我大概可能每兩三集就會需要去封鎖一些人
那當然我是不會去封鎖那些跟我意見相左的，可是我會去封鎖白癡
就是你今天講白癡的話你就立刻被我封鎖，因為我會覺得
還是隻有我這樣想，就是我看到白癡的留言
我會覺得說你正在污染我的腦袋
就是你這種人就應該要立刻出去
所以我很可惜
我只能夠封鎖留言
我覺得最好的做法是
應該是你連
我的頻道都不能夠看到
那這個是最好
只是好像沒有辦法這樣去封鎖別人
但反正總之就是嗯
對如果上面的人比較正常
一點的話就 OK
就像前陣子有一段時間
不是我忘記是 Spotify
還是 Apple
應該是 Spotify
就是全部都在問股票
其實那段時間
我就想把 Spotify 留言的這個機制給關掉
反正總之
我們就是會彈性的去做一些調整啦
因為我真的很討厭笨蛋
下面一位黃三掉太神啦
還敢下來啊
冰鳥這是一個不公平的
比賽啊
欸笑死人
欸
他剛剛打我
我有退嗎
我一步都沒有退
欸欸
你們裁判是怎麼判的
欸不是我一步都沒有退
你判我輸喔
你從桃園新竹
他的手可以穿過
我的巴巴喔是喔真的假的
555 啊
那今天呢風光明媚風和日麗
所以今天的企劃就是早餐喫到飽
哇
這個好多回憶啊
下面一位來
Leo91123，波
癌大你好，我有兩個從國中到現在每天都還是會在羣組講幹話的好兄弟
括號損友
這幾年我們都會一直聊投資的事情，但都不是很正經的那一種
一個把癌大當成神，每個集數當天必聽並認真分析
一個把川普當成神，說跟著偷卡賺就好了
Taco 啦，不是偷卡啦
那希望癌大可以用川普的聲音跟他們兩位說 Kevin 跟 Wilson
祝你們股票都可以買買買，噴噴噴
那這樣就能夠兩個願望一次滿足了，我謝海大
我們的內梗是只要有什麼類似 punchline 的東西就會窩來窩去
甚至到了氾濫的程度
其實有這樣的一些好狗友是滿不錯的事情啦
那川普的話確實是在市場是屬於那種呼風喚雨
只是川普的指標後來也不太好用的原因是因為他搞人
就像上次一下跟你講說他要去奪島，一下說他不要了
所以變成說你會被雙巴巴到死啦
但以前他叫你買股票的時候，那真的是非常準的時間點
所以我覺得川普現在已經是收斂到就是他跟你講說買股票的時候
你就買股票就對了
那下面一位，一路向五萬點，good morning, good afternoon, and good……後面被卡掉了
自南橋湖孟恭去嘎，AKA 官音大，受眾您好
生日快樂，先祝各位捏軟聯盟，快樂寶貝，端午快樂
孟恭會覺得很像楚門世界的主角，走在路上大家都認識你
你卻不認識他們的感覺嗎
總覺得股癌像是陪我長大的節目
有點可以體會到為什麼有人會想追星
希望哪天可以在路上聽到股癌說，I buy you all,can I get the first one
這個是那個黃仁勳的插隊梗
就是他想要去第一個拿到
所以他就幫大家買掉
我不知道可以這樣插隊，如果可以這樣子的話，其實我非常樂意
我非常樂意
就以後如果你看到我在排隊，那你是在我前面，你認識我
你就來跟我講說孟恭幫我付錢，然後我就會幫你付錢
我一定幫你付錢
甚至你不用講說孟恭幫我付錢，你說孟恭你要不要快一點
我就是去前面幫你付錢，因為我超級討厭排隊
我不知道可以這樣插隊啦，因為黃光鑫真的太帥了
所以大家是允許這件事情
世界下蠻多人真的容易被冒犯
我們不確定說你這樣子講會不會有些人說怎樣
有錢了不起喔
但如果說我前面是聽眾，你看到我在排隊，因為我真的超級討厭排隊
你給我一個 Fast Pass, 我一定幫你付錢
下面有位 CCChamp, 超爽 der, 撿到留言密碼的勒
欸孟恭你要去參加 NB 邀請的 10K 路跑嗎
這樣我要砸 NB 參加囉
突然想不到今天可以問什麼， 那我們就一起唱 G-I-J-O-J-A-T-O-D-O-L-A 會，會去跑
只是當然我不確定自己有沒有辦法跑完 10K，因為我沒有跑過這麼長
當兵都是跑 3K 還 5K 嘛
所以第一次跑這麼長
應該前面會去稍微的做一點訓練，大概這樣
下面一位，用川普的語音包說，不懂六七梗的我們是不是老了，嗚嗚嗚
好啦，孟恭寶貝想問，目前有喫什麼健康食品
你說就是那種保養品嗎
蝦油、魚油
綜合維他命， 夜黃， 肌酸
肌酸是很明顯感受到有喫有差的東西
老公有沒有用過 Claude 的 Fable 5 模型
有的話有何感想
有， 好用， 強大， 速度快
我覺得目前 Amprobic 的模型真的都是還蠻屌炮的
3、有沒有一時衝動被洗漱場的經驗
就是明明很看好某黨未來的前景
但因為當天的股價走勢真的太喜而衝動出清
結果當天尾盤又漲回來，如果遇到這種情況會選擇認錯買回還是投入其他標的
最後祝您 60 歲也能夠成博，非常感謝
洗漱場一定有，而且很常見，到現在都還是會有
所謂的洗漱場我會直接把它視為說，反正就是達到我的條件
我開始停利或是停損出去之後，然後接著就立刻開走
這個我都把他視為是洗漱廠
那只是以前遇到洗漱廠就是很被動的接手
現在遇到洗漱廠就是我會把他追回來
然後我追回來的部位我就是洗不掉了
也就是說，他媽的，就算你跌掉我 20%，我都是巴在上面
我可能追回來不會追這麼多，但是我就是巴在上面了
所以一般我會有這個認錯追回啦
就是我是蠻敢追回的，甚至追回是追在漲停價也沒有關係
這個是我近期會這樣子搞
那下面一位，聽老婆話不丟臉，留言密碼測試 1
這些年默默固定聽了孟恭頻道多年
感謝您這一路上的陪伴，有您真好
別的不說，當爸媽之後健康最重要，祝您全家幸福安康美滿
請您幫
我祝福家中老婆大人
6 月 20 號生日快樂感謝老婆有你的付出
才讓這個家完整
那我們希望老婆生日快樂哦
要健康平安
下面一位【科技業背鍋仔阿權】拜託唸到我
好運一直來
孟恭去嘎，您好
小弟目前工作正面臨準備要進入 PIP 或是拿錢走人的窘境
目前還沒有找到下一份工作，又面臨預售屋，明年要交屋
希望借孟恭的金口，祝福我工作瓶頸可以快點跨越
早點更適合自己的工作，那生活家庭都順心
並祝我和好友大寶早日實現買房買車的夢想
明年順利交屋，小弟會捐出五萬的月薪，謝謝，大愛您
我們祝這個兄弟可以早日達成他的目標跟願望
那只是呢，我之前會進行一個大方運動
所以我發現說這邊有很多的蕩生 boy
fucking 蕩生嬰啊，就是他們太摳了啦，他們許一個很大的願望
然後他們摳到爆炸，那只是後來就是像我跟大家分享
我覺得我們這邊有很多聽眾他們又太大方了，就走到一個極限去了
那所以呢，以你的案例，因為你目前正在換工作
同時你預售交屋後面就開始分期要給錢了嘛
那你又要去買車的話，你正在一個支出非常大的階段
在這個階段我建議你先把錢留起來，你要記得你之後
你要還願，你要捐錢，那之後的事情，但你會做到的就好
你先把錢收起來，這也是我跟大家講說，其實很多人在他累積
所謂的第一桶金的初期
你知道你前面的錢
其實是非常重要
的然後你跑去亂買一些東，西亂上一些課或什麼的當然你說是累積自己，可是其實你一直把錢花掉，本身也不是太好的事情，你懂我意思嗎
所以不管是捐或是花前面的幾筆錢
真的要非常非常的小心
我建議這個兄弟好好的存起來
你之後可能不知道
就等到有點彈性之後
你再去把這個願望給還掉
是沒有問題的那些什麼神明還是什麼小的
他們一定會等你
下面一位上星期六的生日
快樂沒有唸到
Semi-Analysis 提到 800V HVDC 延後，AI 電源族羣全面下跌，但臺達電目前主力仍 400V
800V 延後反而可能延長其受益期，另外貿連 KY 買了 Datacom
補足了 Connector 和 PowerShelf 的產品，應該未來更強
怎麼看這波市場的定價邏輯
你講的東西就跟我在上集講的內容基本上是一樣的嘛
我那時候不是跟大家講說
如果你說一些光的東西要遞延
那應該 pluggable 的東西要上去，可是 pluggable 的東西也被殺下去
就代表說其實不是在疊這個嘛
它就是一個市場的情緒的通商嘛
那一樣的道理，如果我今天講說 800VDC 要延後，其實它只有兩個路線去跑嘛
那你說 400V 應該可以持續的走下去
或甚至它會有更長的一個壽居
那它應該要上去嘛，可是為什麼它也跟著掉下去
所以這個就代表說市場它並不是很理性的在做這件事情
那同時是因為現在的盤正好在一個修正的階段
所以我覺得大家不用去太在意
不管是 S emi - A na lysis 還是誰發的什麼報告裡面可能提到的東西
奧塞迪這個，反正你只要記得，你要往過去看，就我跟大家提到的
你去注意一下過去的幾個修正，如果你有經歷過的話
是不是在後面可能過新高
或是說繼續突破的時候就沒有人在意了
一定是這樣子的
所以你不要在短期內去太在意各種消息
各種消息丟出來，你要做的只是去驗證說這個會不會對你的投資不會造成毀滅的打擊
如果不會，如果它只是一個短期的衝擊，你真的不應該太在意它
它就是一個 noise
就有點類似說，我們最近一直舉的例子是 Astralabs 嘛
因為它真的算是一個很經典的案例
就是 Sexyback，從兩百多掉到一百
然後接著下是三百多快四百
「那你還記得快一百的時候也是很多聽眾跑來問我嗎
那我就是跟大家講，雖然我也回答得很心虛，因為股價怎麼會這樣
可是我們看到就不是這樣嘛
我們看到明明就是好的嘛
然後一堆人又在打弱水狗
說什麼這個股價表現是這樣
就是因為什麼光鏡同退啊什麼幾把小的
那現在我問你啊，三到四百人
你要怎麼自洽你的邏輯？」所以其實不用太在意短線這些故事的變化
我還是維持我上集跟大家聊到的
就是這些路線該推的就是會繼續往那個方向去推
它可能在過程中會有一些 pathfinding 或什麼樣的，或是有一些 delay
那是在 RIA 的 project 這邊去 delay，那你要知道在市場裡面現在有很多人都是在去 trade RIA project
也就是說他們是在交易一個正在研發中的東西
那於是他們就會波動很大嘛
因為研發中的東西可能會遞延
它不是像那種量產的東西是非常穩定的
所以你要去接受就是在過程中這樣的一個震盪
它是一個正常的現象來講
好，那今天就這樣，掰